bonjour sedin au temple merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france tout
d'abord que retenez-vous de ce débat
entre eux kamala harris et mike pence
votre reportage l'a très bien dit
effectivement le contraste est très
frappant entre ce débat et le débat
entre trump et byden l'autre jour le
débat a été beaucoup plus respectueux
beaucoup plus calme la parole a été
beaucoup moins coupé même si cnp déjà eu
parfois du mal à couper les deux
candidats mais ce débat s'est déroulé
vraiment de manière relativement poli
c'était vraiment ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
frappé et ce sont des vrais sujets qui
ont été abordés
donc les vrais est le vrai programme en
fait des candidats avec neuf sujets qui
n'ont pas vraiment été abordé dans le
débat entre trump et byden de la
dernière femme
est ce que le but vous vous disiez ce
débat était un petit peu plus apaisé que
le précédent entre dubaï et donald trump
est ce que le but était aussi de redorer
un peu l'image des deux candidats
écornés lors du précédent débat
oui c'est vrai que la dernière fois le
spectacle a été assez affligeant
malheureusement les deux candidats n'ont
pas cessé de se couper la parole donc je
pense que là les enjeux étaient étaient
grands les attentes des américains
également puisque les américains
traversent une crise multiple économique
la crise du coc vide également ils sont
durement touchés dans leur vie dans leur
vie quotidienne et je pense qu'ils
avaient besoin de savoir ce que les deux
candidats et les colistiers pouvait leur
rapporter comme solution ce qui n'avait
pas été le cas la dernière fois alors
deux autres débats auront lieu entre
donald trump et joe biden avant
l'élection présidentielle
est ce que ce débat entre les deux
colistiers est particulièrement attendu
est suivi par les américains je pense
qu'il était crucial parce que donc d'une
part par la cause de la déception de la
de la pro du premier débat
et puis parce que on ne sait pas si les
deux prochains débats auront lieu le
président trump et toujours
malade on connaît pas très bien son état
de santé actuel la maison blanche n'est
pas tout à fait transparente sur la
question théoriquement ils devraient
être encore confiné si l'on en croit les
recommandations des médecins pour le
prochain débat mais il a déclaré qu'il
avait l'intention de le tenir
mais l'incertitude est grande sur sur sa
capacité à être être présents donc je
pense qu'effectivement ce débat entre
les colistiers qui n'est pas normalement
un débat central dans la campagne a sans
doute été plus suivie par les américains
que d'habitude est-ce que six autres
débats entre donald trump et john dryden
a lieu est-ce que vous pensez que les
deux candidats auront retenu la leçon du
premier justement re prendre exemple sur
celui qu'ils ont certainement vu hier
soir
écoutez il faut l'espérer mais on
connaît le style de donald trump puisque
c'était quand même lui qui était
majoritairement la cause de l'échec du
débat dernier puisque c'est lui qui elle
n'a pas être arrêté de couper la parole
pendant pendant tout le débat avec joe
biden et n'a pas respecté les règles qui
avaient été mises en place par les
directeurs de campagne des deux
candidats puisque normalement les termes
du débat sont bien discutée par les
directeurs de campagne en amont avec les
médias et les règles sont claires
est-ce que trump les respectera la
prochaine fois ce n'est pas sûr on sait
qu'il a qui n'a pas l'habitude d'écouter
qui n'a qu'il a l'habitude de couper la
parole c'est son style est en cela mike
pence et extrêmement différent il est
d'ailleurs témoigné à me de multiples
reprises son respect pour son adversaire
vous le disiez tout à l'heure donald
trump est encore malade un de ducobu 19
actuellement est toujours à l' isolement
si il y avait annulation
du ou des débats avant l'élection
présidentielle est ce qu'il pourrait y
avoir des alternatives ou tout
simplement les annuler on peut imaginer
comme on commence à y être habitué avec
cette crise
on peut imaginer un débat en
visioconférence je ne sais pas si cela a
été prévu par les médias par la maison
blanche et parler les campagnes des deux
candidats mais ça pourrait être une
possibilité
plutôt que de rassembler les deux
candidats sur un plateau merci beaucoup
céline neutrons plus d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france rappelle et
que vous êtes professeur agrégé
d'anglais à l'université de nantes merci
beaucoup merci